so why on earth would you consider
geoengineering sounds scary right how
many of you have heard of geoengineering
how many of you think it's a good idea
Yeah right okay me too carefully so
mitigation is all the things we know we
need to do conserve have energy
efficiency transition to solar all of
those things we know we need to do the
trouble with it and why I got into this
sort of band-aid option myself was the
thought that this was not going to
happen in time to prevent great harms
and so that's why I'm in it at least and
when you have that mindset you want to
make sure what you do is reversible
harmless and reversible adaptation are
the sorts of things that we're going to
build higher walls around our cities
we're going to make sure that our
sanitation facilities come out above
water rather than below water things
like that and this is a current reality
in City Planning
so geoengineering in my view is just the
series of planetary band-aids to buy
time it's a possible emergency backup
when I started this work it was with the
feeling I hope this is the backup option
I hope we never need well it turns out
it looks like we're going to need backup
options like this it's trying to buy
time for all those things we know we
need to do but there are people who are
really concerned about the moral hazard
if you and then what does that mean that
means that if you think well we can fix
it the engineers will figure it out we
can just keep on with her you know ten
miles per gallon car and you know burn
the lights all night well no there is no
really good techno fix and so if you're
getting into geoengineering don't make
that assumption that you're going to fix
the root problem you're not you've got
to fix the root problem you're just
giving people time to do that make sure
you first do no harm
make sure I think make sure it's
localized so you understand the effects
you don't suddenly do something
worldwide that you don't understand how
to undo and have an undo plan because
the history of humanity is that there's
always there's always some unintended
consequence so here is something called
the greenhouse gamble how many of you
okay this is a lovely slide if you go to
this website this is about how bad is it
going to get and this is highlighting
with policy and without policy options
when I first saw it the without policy
option looked a lot like the width
policy option it's a way to present
probability wedges so if you said that
you want to go over and spin this wheel
of fortune here and click on it the
chances are good right there they're
less than half that you will end up less
than 5 degrees C temperature rise
without policy that's a horrifying
thought the chances are very good that
you will end up above 5 degrees C maybe
above 7 degrees C temperature rise by
2100 if we don't change anything even if
we put in the policies that they're
advising the chances are still sort of
almost half that we're going to end up
above 2 degrees C temperature rise why
do we care we care because there are a
host of impacts for every single degree
that we increase there are there are
terrible impacts you probably can't read
these very well but this was a brilliant
graphic that terry root used to be a
professor here in mmm climate change
pressures on species was one of her
specialties part of the IPCC the
internet Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change and she worked with a
graphic artist to make some of the 2007
assessment conclusions accessible as a
graphic as a visual that we can see this
is worth drinking in so the the
difference between rising 1 degree C 2
degrees C and 5 degrees C is all the
difference in the world for instance
increased risk of extinction for 20 to
30% of known species with 2 degrees C
rise vs. extinction not even risk
extinction of more than 40% of known
species you know our web of life
disappearing around us so there's a
reason why you really fear if you're
gonna get up in this very high region
there I mean there there's enough
problems if you're down here why is this
happening it's happening basically
because we sort of
change the stable equilibrium setpoint
if you will of what the temperature of
our atmosphere is as we're changing its
composition so we have this balance as
we always have between incoming energy
and outgoing energy but there's we
changed what that stable set point is if
we had no atmosphere at all we'd be like
the moon right very different set points
so we changed the composition of our
atmosphere there are all kinds of things
that you can look at I forget if this
goes live I guess not
if you look up these slides later by
viewing the fact I guess I'll put the
slides on a course work site too so you
can look at them and look up these
sources you can play with these yourself
and what you get to do is start clicking
on what's how much of this effect is
land use or ozone or aerosols or
greenhouse gases so that you can see
what in the best assessment of climate
scientists what is it that's causing
this we are out of bounds now we are
running an experiment that hasn't been
run wearing conditions that haven't been
seen on earth in at least the last
800,000 years this is from John kumys
book where we're just way out of sight
on co2 and the no policy cases for
greenhouse gas concentrations it's going
to be big and there are other gases to
worry about too methane actually is
worse than co2
you know the per molecule and and
there's no end in sight and this thing
is saying this is the MIT no policy case
the five degrees C so this is Copenhagen
2009 diagnosis oh and then and so the
fifth assessment report had even more
from the IPCC which is about 2,000
climate scientists around the world UN
appointed body trying to figure out what
all this means I mean you can hardly get
a more impartial and more bias towards
conservative statements body of
scientists and then this group and what
you're seeing is co2 going up summer sea
ice extent going down ocean heat content
going up sea level rises happening
you know it's where's the good news here
the projection is here global mean sea
level rise depending what model you have
you have you have some irony's here back
in the
days 1962 one of the big oil companies
was advertising that they supply enough
energy to melt 7 million tons of glacier
this was a really powerful statement
they were proud of this it turns out
that for once advertisements didn't lie
these are the saucer
these are the sorts of costs that people
were estimating a couple years ago for
you know just a few coastal cities I
didn't want to swamp you with all of
them but per year you know in New York
City spending 2 billion dollars per year
to fend off rising sea level effects on
it's very you know water oriented city
now this is an exaggeration so far right
graphic artists have their fun also have
their fun this didn't happen yet and
then there are really fascinating things
like how does the u.s. generate its
electricity you know you can see there
are changes there are rays of hope for
sure but it becomes really interesting
so this is coal natural gas oil you know
again you can look at the slides after I
put them on on our site and that there's
no co2 techno fix is this this
particular stories headline because you
know we have other things happening -
besides co2 in the atmosphere we have
co2 in the oceans and it's certainly not
helping ocean health at all and then
there's the whole contention climate
scientists seem pretty sure about this
that because we have melted so much ice
in the Arctic we've actually
destabilized what was historically a
very low temperature sort of anchor
point to the rest of climate so that the
jet stream has now gotten destabilized
so if there's any sort of perturbation
oh it jumped ahead for me you can have
terrific weather changes and terrific
storms more and more intense storms with
horrible human costs so you know it's
not it's not great
we're in hottest summers coldest winters
heat and drought fish dying desperate
options being taken to conserve water
and pressure pressure pressure on all
the rest of the species that share this
planet with the caesars these are slides
from Terry
about just how difficult it is for
species you know if you're pressured
because it's too hot here and you need
to migrate where your food is well you
may be encountering a new predator I
mean it's part of what drives when
climate change is driving change like
this part of what drives species extinct
and so it's just you know we've gone
from what used to be less than one
species in a thousand over a thousand
years dying to what is now about one in
ten over so so less than one in a
thousand to one in ten so we are in the
beginning of the sixth the sixth wave of
extinction so not so good so you know
Calvin and Hobbes are getting rather
discouraged here packing
yep get your toothbrush Hobbes we're out
of here that's it's an outrage how
grown-ups have polluted the earth I
refuse to inherit a spoil planet I'm
leaving really where to and that is the
question right we're not there yet
so again the slide I showed you before
that's why you would consider
geoengineering but it has these horribly
complex issues possible unintended
consequences possible irreversibility
for some of the options and of course
who governs it that's one of the big
mysteries that Armand and I run into who
decides once you develop this and doing
nothing you know that's what we got well
there's a lot right there's huge
wildfires right now in our neighborhood
and there are many many ideas people
have many many ideas all looking at what
the Earth's energy balance is and what
we can do about it more proposals I mean
you will find more and more they tend to
sort out in a couple of different things
attempts to control long wave or short
wave radiation attempts to do surface
modification some of us so two distinct
strategies the way some people sort it
out one of the most common kinds of
geoengineering you'll hear about is the
kind where people are trying to mimic
what volcanoes do and so many people
when you hear geoengineering are
thinking about this and this was the
idea to put stratospheric
sulfate aerosols originally now they're
moving on to other kinds of aerosols in
the atmosphere to mimic what's been
observed that when volcanoes erupt you
end up getting temperature suppression
which is interesting okay there's our
heat shield why don't we just do that
and this is an option that many people
are studying seriously but they're
finding more and more and thank goodness
they're studying it so you don't just
suddenly adapt adopt it when your backs
are to the wall without studying it
because there are some real consequences
it changes it changes rainfall patterns
it changes where droughts will be it
actually when you turn it on you could
suddenly this is courtesy of Ken caldera
who is a big and and very credible
advocate for let's at least study what's
happening here so we don't just adopt it
you know foolishly without knowing what
we're getting into and if you do this
you can drop temperatures pretty quickly
so if it's only about temperature this
could look interesting the thing that
worries me a lot about it is well there
doesn't seem to be an undo switch and if
you stop and you're gradually getting
this back out of your atmosphere this is
why there really isn't an easy undo what
happens is that you tend to get up to
not quite the temperature you would have
been otherwise but you tend to have a
pretty quick rise even faster than you
would have had originally to get back
near that original set point you would
have had because the world situation is
still you know getting more and more co2
into the atmosphere changing the
setpoint and if you do that then you are
ending up putting even more pressure on
species and your your changes are even
more sudden so that's that's one of the
worries there at least people are really
studying it hard so then we get to what
I've been working on and I'll try to
zoom through this quickly in the final
lecture of the class I will go over this
a bit more as well so I can afford to
zoom so this is one climate change
effect that I thought was really
important to look at and it's the
disappearance of multi-year ice which
to be the most reflective over the last
three decades and it's disappeared to an
astonishing degree this is satellite
imagery by rigger and Wallis they were
actually looking at the age of the ice
but the age correlates pretty well with
the reflectivity of the ice and the
problem that we have is that as it
disappears in the summer these are June
to June here in the summer you take in
more and more energy from the Summer Sun
than you would have had back just three
decades ago used to be able to reflect
let's say and loose numbers 95% of
sunlight that would be falling on this
highly reflective ice now you know off
this you're reflecting maybe 5% off very
young ice so it's a real problem and it
contributes right now about a third of
global temperature rise and so it's a
big deal and it's why we have from the
IPCC assessments looking at ice loss
it's why we have this I never have fixed
this darn thing I added the 2012 info
here this goes through 2007 basically
what all the IPCC assessments were were
this range but what actually happened
was this drop off the cliff of of ice
and so we've lost about 50% of our area
of ice and we have left about 25% of our
volume so it's not not so good so that's
all a positive feedback so the warmer
things get the faster what remains and
when I started this there was 20% of
global temperature rise to this ten
years ago now it's a third of global
temperature rise so we have a simple
mission why don't we look at this as a
materials problem and try to put some
reflective materials that will allow us
to fend off some of that sunlight and
try to look for the most benign
materials possible so that's what we've
done and we're applying it to water
right now so we're trying to slow
climate driven ice loss and we're trying
to slow evaporative loss from reservoirs
because our drought is it's coming along
and this is a big deal too and as I say
I'll talk about it more in future but
basically we're floating material or
placing material on ice or on water to
be able to
continue having the reflectivity and the
idea is that eventually we could maybe
reboot the multi-year ice in the Arctic
at least in strategic locations to try
to slow this ever hastening positive
feedback effect there are other things
that can do you know it'll keep things
cooler we could also perhaps prevent the
methane release that is another one of
these trigger points that's coming at us
in climate change and there is a great
value in making reversible changes it's
one of the things I love about our Mons
project it's it's something that is
inherently more reversible than many
things that you could think of and ours
is - you could remove it you could sync
it you could put suit - undo the effects
because what we have right now is you
know think of this as temperature or co2
uncontrolled right things are spinning
out of control
think of oh I don't know accidentally
provoking the next I say it just over
correcting it in the other direction
right oh the climate models were wrong
oh this thing was too effective but if
you have something that you can undo
then you you have the ability to
carefully and locally tweak things in so
that you can tune it to just right
whatever that is and so we've been
working hard on water we've been working
hard on ice we've we've been working as
a nonprofit that is one way to make sure
that we don't have a profit motive kind
of complicating what what our motives
are we're just trying to fix the problem
and we've done some field tests so you
know wherever we could get permission to
work that seemed really relevant to us
and so we've been around a bit on the
getting getting this tested out in the
water we're about to move into a really
nice pond that actually a landowner is
reconstructing for us to make it an
ideal test site which is pretty lovely
and we've got a nice team of folks this
is our test pond in Minnesota with the
homeowner and our team there that's also
Minnesota this is from Barrow which is
right in the Arctic Ocean you know
abutting the Arctic Ocean and this is
some of our testing up there what we
head up there and this is sort of where
we've been you know as we and we're not
in Maine yet we're thinking about it
hard
so these are where we've done some
testing just to try to prove out does
this work and you can do this sort of
thing on kind of a shoestring although
fortunately we've got enough of a
donation now we're beginning to turn it
into a part of our day jobs which says
that now we've developed some of the
fundamentals we can start trying to get
it out the door actually spend daylight
hours working on it and then we can
apply the same sort of techniques to
water and it turns out it really works
and we we reach a lower temperature
lower peak temperature daily even in
teeny pools here is what the pond used
to look like with a whole bunch of high
school interns and and my coworker here
and we were just really getting this
thing ready to go and we're excited
about it we conserve water and we keep
lower temperatures and both of those are
great for having drinking water and
preserving wildlife and I could as you
can tell go on all day but I won't
because we have our mont and here is
here is one way to depict you you get to
depict yourself i will say as armand is
coming up to take over and we're pull up
his slides in a second here this is sort
of how I'm viewing the earth for the
purposes of this class this fragile
bubble that we're trying to carefully do
something so as you go through the class
I'm hoping you'll think what would you
carefully try and we'll see how much
time there is for questions at the end
okay thank you so thank you for inviting
me Leslie and to talk about her work and
you know it's sort of strange I I was at
this university as a graduate student 50
years ago was just about this time I
certainly didn't think that fifty years
later I'd be speaking here about climate
change actually so but anyway you never
know what's going to happen so this is a
project that we started six seven years
ago had requests from actually people
that work with gates essentially this is
not the Gates Foundation but it's it's a
private initiative and so the people in
that room there are you know people that
I've worked with me in my career or this
PhD in
in chemical engineering this is a PhD in
mechanical engineering and so you know
we're all in our 60s 70s and one of them
in his 80s and so you know this between
the four or five of us
you got like 250 years of experience
it's various fields let's see no machine
again okay so what is and you know what
while with some people that are
basically retired you know really get
start working on this and in the
beginning this was flag Estero most of
us are gone through style and done
startups and so we spend $60 recognize
quite as much anymore because you know
if you seen a trajectory of climate
change is really very very disturbing
mostly I have children and grandchildren
and that's really wiring in for their so
you know what is geoengineering
well you say oh it's the deliberate
judicial intervention in the climate
system now that's a lot easier said than
done
you know we we in fact we can't even
change you know you think about making
it rain it doesn't work most of the time
but it's about 50% fact National Academy
of Science in you can't predict it so
you know at best it's a stopgap measure
essentially right but it that doesn't
mean it could be extraordinary useful
okay and it's certainly not a substitute
for decarbonisation you know so some
well and gas company like these programs
actually very much because they think
they can keep on doing what they're
doing with that that's not the intent so
it actually happened why this sort of
took up now Paul Crutzen Nobel Prize
winners for their ozone hole so roll of
paper you know plan to play paper in I
forgot which magazine and so this really
called the stern you know Paul is a very
deliberate very soft-spoken guy and this
coming out say now we have to remedy the
the thing it's the end of the world I
mean people are gonna believe it so
people actually you know try to convince
not to write this and so when he wrote
it and us on the other side there was
why we shouldn't be doing is that a
matter of fact but you know what you
know you said this you know these are
all pious thoughts that we have of
reducing the carbon it promise isn't
going to happen in time and that may
still be the truth so why on earth with
all these dishes you know what we want
to do this and sort of describe it in
the idea of Eli Kentish the science
writer is
you know is this a bad idea whose time
has come so you know maybe it is so why
if you look at it so 2015 was the
hottest year on record right so this is
the hottest years over the last that we
ever measured I noticed I can't quite
read in them but all of them are in the
2000 are just close to it right and I
was sort of disturbing and then came you
know 2016 so by some measures in March
actually okay we crushed the thresholds
of one and a half degree C for a few
days and if you look at it so you know
that in general I mean in December we
agreed that all right
you know in Paris and that was a very
good meeting who people agreed all right
you know you're gonna get two degrees C
for sure and really gonna have to it we
should really like the one and a half
well two months later before it's even
inked will there yeah that's not a good
sign so in February 2016 from what I
heard it actually didn't freeze on the
North Pole okay this year for on New
Year's Day so if you look at it so for
one day there with one and a half did we
see all over the planet and the northern
atmosphere was two point seven six
degrees C warmer this is very very
disturbing so what are we starting to do
you know you see these very sad things
happening okay so if you have the money
like this Swiss you spend twelve million
dollars on duct-taping glaciers right
that's what you do
alright well you know it's may lose the
glaciers maybe that's not the end of the
world but for these people in the end is
that is the end of the world and so what
they start doing
they're basically whitewashing the tops
of the monks all right and rather that's
kind of work or not so what you're
trying to do is lower the climate there
a little bit so the snow is kind of late
because yeah if they don't have the
glaciers there ain't gonna be any water
in the summer and that's the end of a
lot of the cities along these mummies
along the back of the n DS so if you
sort of look and it's the best graph I
know you may know better ones
essentially you know twelve thousand
years ago we went on this period the
whole thing right it's a very benign
period and so before that we've been up
and down by four or five degrees these
various ice ages but we're lucky enough
essentially come over here and so for
this many
many years essentially we had that this
is actually made from about sixty
proxies alright so tree rings and all
that kind of stuff and carbon dating and
all that stuff so we're sliding into the
night no I coming ice age until we hit
the Industrial Revolution and we shoot
up so this is the ice melt in Greenland
you know what white isn't melting and
what red is melting during that summer
and you see that since 2013
you know it's melting everywhere
realistically this isn't the first time
that happened it seems that happened
before but it's another very disturbing
factor so this is leslie is talking
about this here this is the IPCC
prediction for the ice in the Arctic
okay and this is where the track that
we're on so we have said all the climate
scientists are working on and I have a
better that by 2020
it's going to be gone in September now
freezes back every year used to mean
three meters thick it's not 50
centimeters thick so it it you know it
breaks up much easier because it's much
thinner and so all I got so everything
is sort of going much faster than we
thought and you know let me just make a
comment tonight IPCC you know it's not
that these guys that don't know what
they're doing
don't very smart guys I mean I I'm not a
climate scientist I'm just simple
engineer and physicist or quite a
physicist but basically what actually
happened these decisions I made by
consensus so if there's some innate
doesn't Saudi Arabia doesn't like it and
say they said you know that that's not
acceptable so you sit there for days or
weeks essentially working on you know
working on one word and so that's what
happens you have the ones here that what
comes out is common consensus which is
written our consensus which is the
guidance the lowest common denominator
they're thriving it so this is why this
happens so last week there was a
conference in Oxford up about one and a
half degrees C so we have the Paris
conference and then people say well
you're saying we better take a look at
it so this is sort of convened okay and
this is not from a you know these
they're all kind and scientists then
they're observers that this is a
comments from an observer that I got you
know we're not gonna make one I have to
greasy that's just this no way of doing
what I have a greasy the only way are we
gonna make one a helical EC if we are on
war footing which we're not doing so if
you sort of look what
say well we make treat agree see with
what we have now you know in the in the
in the Paris Accord the Paris of course
you know say that we're gonna take 800
you got o of carbon out of the
atmosphere okay and put it on the ground
somewhere yeah we don't know yet how to
do that and may require a turn of the
stuff that we now use for for
agriculture you know this is so well
happening but so so anyway this this is
the lemon that with it and so you see
gradually with all these things there if
we're gonna have to go to the greasy
alright which is sort of the threshold
that say you can't go any farther
we probably sadly are gonna have to do
geoengineering and it's not a pretty
picture but Antonio that's just the way
it is
so what we do for this is you know the
best one says solar radiation monument
is the same graph that Leslie show so
you can do this in various ways you can
do this in the stratosphere you can do
this in the stratosphere that's we're
working and then you can do it on the
ground over here essentially that Leslie
is like now so you have you know they're
actually cloth soap here the sinners
cloths
and you would like to remove those you
don't miss oh we're gonna make more
cloth so to speak but these ones you
would like to remove because what
they're very good at letting light
through we detect infrared radiation so
they're very high and you know people
are actually seriously looking and this
they're mostly ice plots that's why that
happens and say I have to put us
business solvent to remove but anyway so
these are various ways so I just gotta
see a little word about static Salter
you know so this is the Pinatubo you
know that you saw one and a half a
degree dish there in in 1815 when
Napoleon was defeated you may remember
this from that they couldn't grow any
crops actually in all the crops failed
worldwide that was because mon tambura
explore it was much much lighter as for
two or three years there was famine all
over the world because of that
particular explosion so when Mount
Pinatubo put about 20 million ton of
sulfur in the stratosphere is you know
depending on the size and stays on a
couple years so you deliver the sulfur
here
yeah one to two million ton period and
you do this very very gradually try to
compensate
for half the temperature rise all right
you know this you know this one airplane
and you spray then look very pretty
you spray some furyk acid and that's
very rapidly converted into a sulfate
and survives terrible hairspray and all
that kind of stuff it's a small fraction
of the stuff that sulfur that we already
put an outfit with the coal plants and
all that kind of stuff so it's maybe
less than a percent of that so the cost
is very modest this is a few billion
dollars per year and there are
individuals on the world that can afford
to do that and it's likely to work
effectively so it's it's unfortunately
eminently doable when you think about it
now what are the disadvantage is you
know it's difficult to the seat of
public I don't see anyone certainly
joining up and saying you know I'm gonna
go for this right it's difficult to do
in a small scale so the stuff we're
gonna do we can do this in a little
corner they laugh and a little call of
the world you know to do it is done all
over the world right and it's gonna go
up in the stratosphere it's going to
diffuse very very rapidly so it can't be
on undone in a short time when things go
wrong it stopped there for a couple of
years you know that's what you had so
you know and sulfur maybe played the
ozone layer you know that we have
wholesome the the holes in they are
indeed in the with the ozone horror
typically around the poles that's
because we have ice crystals there and
so each time you have a a crystal or a
particle essentially that tends to
catalyze the reaction of the ozone
essentially with with the with the CFCs
that are there so you're gonna see
someone usually effects I you know
you're gonna had the sky is gonna be a
little whiter than all that kind of
stuff essentially that that's something
that was it so now to tell you the truth
the problem I got to put sulfur up there
they're working very very hard to
actually find another particle that
doesn't do sulfur but software is just
happens to be unusually easy to and so
they I think they actually have a
solution this is a harbor crew and so
they they I think they have an auto
particle which then published it and it
doesn't catalyze the reaction but but
it's probably not nearly as easy to this
person so marie-claude brightening is
something that was invented by guy
working up with the skits you know open
there in the hills in England and his
son says you know wait look at it the
clouds are like a mirror and he started
thinking about it so so what we do is we
well let me just say 25% of the oceans
right are covered with what called
marine boundary layer clouds and you go
to the coast over here that's the kind
of cloth that you have and it's not a
very white cloth okay and that's because
it's typically it doesn't have any make
droplets in it so swimming activities on
the other 30% now if something is 95
percent you can't do anything about it
you know I go to 96 percent by a lot of
effort it doesn't change the
reflectivity but something is 30% you
can do something with it and it's
relatively easy to change so if you
could change that reflectivity by about
six percent which is quite reasonable
number okay and do you do that worldwide
which is easier said than done you you
could change the reflectivity by the
earth about one percent one percent is
about three watts per square meter
that'd be enough to offset doubling of
co2 eternally you don't do anything
about anything else but thermally you
could offset the you know the radiation
essentially is quite impressive
so you know what you think well this
conceptually an environmental be design
there is no such thing you know all
these things have consequences that we
hadn't foreseen but this is why you have
to study it so our group we don't
advocate that should be pry this we
advocate that you do the research on
this because if you have an emergency
you've got to know what the Constituent
will be if you not have to be prices so
we're actually you know so we're from
very beginning we knew that we
eventually would work with University of
Washington which has a Joint Institute
for the ocean in the atmosphere so a
little bit of elementary cloud physics
you know a cloth consists of goblets and
ten microns in diameter right and say
these clouds typically have about a
hundred droplets of these per cubic
centimeter and so think of the cloud
SATs milk you know if I take a glass of
milk and dilute it doesn't look quite
the same at this stuff so I don't know
if you're familiar with multiple
scattering so you know the the the more
particles the more surfaces you had the
more reflection and the whiter it looks
essentially so so these droplets
actually form what you need is a nucleus
if you have a supersaturation
you know the water will usually
in the air but it doesn't make it on the
air in super saturation of 400% before
you make droplets spontaneously so that
never happens in nature you have a half
a percent or a small fraction of a
percent so what you need is a it's a
nucleus and that can come from from very
hot small house kopecks also sort of
salt and sulfate so where do they come
from
well so of course over the land we
provide lots of them but over the ocean
it's very often from you have air
bubbles that break up you know the thing
and so that's very thin layer breaks up
and a very few twenty or thirty on
average essentially managed to escape
and go up essentially so what happens
there there then you know the warming
arises it expands and cool you have a
little bit of over saturation I have a
percent and then these depending on its
mass this thing converts in a droplet
for good and that's it and that's how
you form a clot so this is reflectivity
for example you say for example you take
this is the Swami model I think I
develop this theory and prove enough to
be really correct so if you take a cloth
that's about 150 meters thick right and
so I can't do this very well over here
so you have like you know twenty-five
thirty-six percent you double it
essentially you go to two hundred
particles say okay you know 242 we have
a six or seven percent change that's the
way it works quite simple so will this
work well you know probably yes so the
ships already to some degree do this
right so the ships burn why do they do
this because the burn in Bunker oil so
we took all the sulfur now you spin me
and the gasoline and took it out of it
put it in a bunker oil bunker oil is
very you know it's very tough stuff here
you have to heat it to shove it in the
snow so you're basically a great deal of
sulfur that's in there let's say we make
sulfates and so you you know sulfates do
exactly the same stuff in the socio you
see these traces over here of the ships
going and then this is on the Gulf of
Biscayne this is Spain and Portugal this
is over the coast of California
this is tore the regions where this
happens all the time so it's likely to
work so you know and then so this is
sort of sort of a rogue science site I
mean this is when we started in this six
seven years ago this was sort of
sort of like a really wacky idea why
anyone talk about it
and you know so so we had an article
actually in the in the Economist by by a
longish Martin about our thing and he
says you know spray-and-pray and we
believe that Pope Francis is say you
know let's pray and so we think we're
now blessed by people endorsement
essentially to go ahead with this stuff
at least the research so the project
started about you know there's there's
been 20 years of modeling in this you
know and so people like to model
essentially but you essentially Robert
hits to hit the road at some time and so
the question is can you really make this
spray that you're talking about right in
a reasonable way so I was invited to an
Edinburgh confidence essentially you
know by Pfizer which is gates funds for
innovative climate and research and so
you know I was asked to start a project
on this here in there in the valley
because you know they and you know like
sort of yes not knowing any better and
so that was seven years of my life they
have put into this so it's mostly a
volunteer effort we had some funds from
in the beginning and we start about 2009
so what have you done since well we yeah
you know we identified three methods one
of them very promising you know and we
we don't have a corporate you know this
is not a corporate structure scientific
experiment we started with 12 volunteers
and about five left over here and this
is sort of a geriatric crew if you're
not in a hospital or rehab or something
like that you've managed to put if you
are working on your citizenship so
that's whatever and so University of
Washington is now formally taking over
the project and we're actually apart
from that connected to an international
group of scientists that are very
interested in this in sort of laminated
a so you know have enormous goodwill and
cooperation from numerous outside so we
we don't have any funds anymore so
everybody works for free and I cover the
expenses which are minimal because we
all work in start-up and so but you know
I so I I got like sheets of diamond you
know that somebody made for me for like
changing for to body of boxes or
biscotti and stuff like that so this is
the way that we work actually
so you can't take battle on this stuff
because you do this people say you're in
it for the money you know that's what
you're really doing and there was this
experiment and on that people started
and one guy taking on a patent and all
hell broke loose and so we said you know
just no pants period that's it so we you
know if we'd gone to seven complex
presentation and three article
presentation and so you know if you're
interested in this we're very actively
interesting young people we're getting
older and older essentially and and for
formal cooperation so this is a grueling
mission so what what do I want to do
well we want to develop a small that
prototype of spree minute okay it's
suitable for a research ship
implementation should be easy to scale
up so what we're all about 10 to the 15
nuclei per second okay
so it's a billion times a million and
the salt crystal that we want 50 to 80
about it you know I can have it we
really would like to have it in a very
narrow distribution unfortunately you
know that doesn't always work so the
energy requirements are secondary it is
poison but it should be the business of
it know why does this stuff work well it
works because that you know so if we
make a cloud right so I make a cloth and
it's say a mile by a mile that reflects
up there at two and a half gigawatts of
power right I mean I've said 1 watts per
square meter so and it took me only
maybe a couple hundred watts to make it
and it and it stayed there for three
days etc so you get this you know fifty
to a hundred million multiplier in the
energy that you put in versus the stuff
that you get out this is why this work
now if you're gonna try to deal in the
same way with ocean acidification which
is a real big problem you don't have
that multiplier for every molecule that
you have there you're gonna have to add
another molecule to compensate it and
that that's why this is so attractive
and that's why people looking at this so
the first thing is some of you may be
familiar this you know well you make
some small holes making small holes now
these days with you know micromachining
and piece of cake and that's sort of
what I did in my career at least part
time and so you make very small holes
and they push water to it let's see what
all right so we're spraying seawater
right and it evaporates and here we come
in the salt nuclear and
or they they may stay a droplet doesn't
matter it's the amount of salt that you
have in it so you do this you know and
you put a thing on it this breaks up
perfectly right and you actually may
have heard that if you if you take your
water nozzles you know for regard nozzle
sometimes you can hear it sing let's go
here and break up of all those little
jets that out there so anyway I I did
this some sort of 1971 45 years ago a
Xerox and made droplets and and toner
all exactly the same size unfortunately
the number the holes that you use for
this stuff are in order of you know
point five nine my command below and
that's very difficult to maintain you
know against all expectations we managed
to will spray big bubble essentially 50
gallon through a five one five micron
hole and that was I was astounded but
basically you know a so we were quite
familiar with all the filtration
technology in the semiconductor industry
and equipment industry and so that
worked for five micron but for 0.5
micron we couldn't make it to work so
smaller guys like yourself me doing this
is a this is by far the most efficient
way of doing it of energy efficient way
of doing if you can make it do so then
you think a little harder and you say
alright wow I gotta do this okay so what
you do is you you take a big so
maybe that's one is 20 micron that's not
bees that's a piece of cake keep that
open
now put a big electric field over it and
you pull on it and what you get is on
the direct conditions you get a very
narrow jet coming out that's called a
Taylor instability and that jet maybe
hunger to turn 100 to 200 nanometer in
diameter that's exactly what you want
okay that's the kind of diameter that
you want and you can do this experiment
yourself you just take a pen and put
salt water to it push a little bit and
put it feel and you see that this works
so mrs. Cole electrospray is a
well-known technique people have used
this before and and the only problem is
that from each one of these yets
you're about 10 to the 7 to 10 to the
8th power go the 10 to the 15 you're
gonna have to make 10 to the 7 to 10 to
the 8 of them something like that
so you know they are actually the
particles that come out are very very
mono dispersed as a matter of fact as it
turns out because they break up very
nicely so how you do that well you you
you know we I worked at HP and we a lot
of guys working with us on this project
quite from HP so you sort of we would do
the same technology so here is the see
whether on the pressure this very little
pressure so you have a filter over here
to put this through this is like you
know a 20 micron hole so this is a
hundred micron over here or something
like that or whatever you so you you
have a little bit of air pressure
because otherwise you can have break
down over here the feel that these tips
are enormous they're million of volts
per per centimeter
I mean much much higher than atmospheric
breakdown know usually you can do that
or add a very small tip and so the air
blows it through and a powder comes out
and this so this is an electrode so this
is how you make a hundred million of
them the same time so this is the you
know the technology speedos and so what
you do is you know to make this fair
thing you make this out of resist the
only part that that is dry resist there
is no metal I mean the metal is just
extracting it all but it's quite an
expensive so this this looks very
attractive except we didn't have the
means and and lab essentially to do that
but if you ever going to deploy this
this will be a good way to come back to
it so so then we you know he's sort of
some of us were in the pharmaceutical
industry and say you know they use this
supercritical
you know processes to so so
supercritical seawater it you know it's
basically the stuff that comes off all
these fishes in the ocean right that's
why it's being studied in fact by can
spits very used to be there was a
president of this university when I was
here as a matter of fact and couldn't
deal with all the you know the worst
thought that was going on here at that
particular time but anyway so
fortunately for us human back to
academics and studied this sea water
because the chemistry of this becomes
very complicated very easy to get
confused for especially for electrical
engineers or mechanical engineer so what
you do it is so you take water alright
and and you you heat it under pressure
okay so and quite high two hundred
universe for you know seven degree C it
becomes this gas I but
sort of like a fluid and it's sort of
like a fascist super Elsa supercritical
water right and so the point of its
normally when you evaporate watering and
heat it okay to the salt stay behind in
this building in case salt is all in the
fluid so the salt is in that fluid that
sort of behavior easily and so you know
that there has no surface tension and
begins like you know as gas like
viscosity so the hip socket has should
spray like a gas and lo and behold that
happens so and so what you do over here
you feel in your your gas here there's a
heater block at the right temperature
it's at its center I know if there it
comes the critical short so you see this
over here so all these pictures all
right are basically illuminated by white
light so this is the phenomena of
scattering so the particles are sort of
micron okay you got white light yeah
that's what you typically have so you
illuminate it on the side with white
light okay when you actually come in the
right range you have really scattering
and so what you see now the light turns
blue and we actually comes when it comes
very very small we serve and work it
virtually disappears because you don't
even the Rayleigh scattering goes down
as six power of the diameter so you know
that that sort of works wonderfully well
the only problem is the only thing that
can stand this corrosion is basically
diamond and gold so you take a sapphire
nozzle along this and it lasts a quarter
of an hour so the only thing that is so
so critical see I mean see whether is mm
sorry
clearly the water is used for extraction
of you know various things essentially
including fuels that's very promising
that it's difficult to do but Sewall the
critical sea water is extraordinary
corrosive in northern magnetars much so
it it just can't be done on a reasonable
scale so so then we ran to a you know
something else suggest to us by Purdue
University it's it's got this
effervescent atomization there's big
word to saying you know that you you
mixing water and an air all right
together so you can do the C by the
water in the center and the gas coming
in or you put gas over there you get the
water coming in alright so doesn't make
much difference
so but this is the interesting part
about it okay so normally when you have
a nozzle over here and I'm sure you'd
think this is the high-pressure here
there's a low pressure right
unfortunately this is shifted you think
that you're gonna drop all the pressure
okay over this thing over here right
that's what normally happens but when
you mix these two together okay then you
actually have you have very low velocity
of sound velocity and what happens you
have chalk throw and in this section
over here the velocity of the medium
can't go any faster than the speed of
song and what happens is that you can't
drop the pressure so when you come out
over here you still have more than half
the pressure left over so here you may
have 50 or a whole atmosphere you have
50 atmosphere left over so what happens
then is that under the right conditions
and of course once you know what what
you want to go after you can stimulate
it you make this very thin layer that
comes out just around the surface and
the layer is just a few microns thick so
now I have a layer as a few microns
thick and 50 atmosphere of pressure over
there and it blows apart into very small
particles and that's exactly what you
want so this is a nozzle this is tuna
mackerel nozzle and this is four or five
millimeters so you see enormous rapidly
expansion and going forward and there
are three trillion particles droplets
coming out of that nozzle okay per
second at one single nozzle so you know
then you say well this looks wonderfully
on so you you measure the distribution
of this in the air and you know that
takes some doing kousser aerosol is a
very tricky field and together I did
cementation and while under some
condition you got a perfectly block
normal distribution problems so this is
exactly what we need ah well there's
only one problem it's an almost log
normal distribution and so this tail
goes out over here and it goes on and
out very very low but unfortunately goes
like the third power so what you have is
almost 90 percent of the masses over
here and ten percent of the mass is over
there so you're not spraying very
efficiently it's good enough actually to
do the experiment but it's not
necessarily the most efficient system so
we now been playing around this for gosh
a year
time flies when you're having fun and so
we now have system that on occasion do
four times better actually than that
with very simple means so it's ready for
action so what would we like to do we
like to build a prototype now and Seraph
you know this is in the lab we spray
this in the lab we measure in the lab
okay
seems fine so what you get is yeah you
you buy one off you get an old one of
these you know snow launcher this is
snow makers right
and so in that's got a couple hunger we
need about 300 nozzles essentially that
you put in over here that's how it snow
maker is made essentially right and so
then you put a big fan on it and this is
what happens so you throw this up in the
air but the particles that we throwing
up a thousand times smaller then once
you have in the snow making that's the
difference right so so you would like to
do this on and see that's where you're
gonna do that but it's much cheaper to
do this on land so we do this somewhere
near Monterey and so you get a few of
these trucks over here and so what you
put on there is your your take off this
the snowblower that you have tin and you
put a you know a cubic meter of sea
weather and you put in your compressor
to say all the energy goes in
compressing the air essentially and then
you have a diesel generator in the back
and you have no I have a mobile unit
that cost 100 of the experiments that
you do on a ship and as long as you have
an influx of Maritim air the experiment
is much easier to do so that's what
we're working to know and that's what
we're looking for funds for so what are
the application of this marine cloud
brightening all right well you know it's
a great tool for cloud studies okay
cloths have the largest unknown in a
climate studies right so you some models
come up with - and others come up with
four well the difference between two and
four is dramatic you know - will
probably do well you know its prosperous
something else but for according to the
World Bank and they have courses on this
by the way as you can look up on the web
on Coursera you can't have an organized
society as we have you know we'll
survive but I'm gonna be very pretty so
this is why it's very important to know
why what you know what this is the first
that people may know you have clawed
chambers and all that kind of stuff
where they do this in laboratory but
this is real life this is enough nuclei
that four or five of them you can do
this essentially and follow the nuclei
they're going rotation you can measure
this with their place and all that kind
of stuff so that that's half our
intention and so you know what could us
could you do it well and along the coast
of California you know as a graduate
student here in the sixties I would wake
up every morning and you know I'd be
sixty degrees C and be cloudy and that's
what it was and then by eleven o'clock
the clouds would break up essentially
and sort of get to 75 and in don't have
any date is same so one day I remember
in September I went to 91 degrees C
Fahrenheit and people thought you know
that the the world is coming to an end I
mean we were not prepared for this stuff
well it's not only the same where I live
in Portola Valley the clothes are gone
every day and most I'd see in the valley
over here you know what climate has
changed and so the redwoods know that
and they're actually straining very hard
so they don't have the fog anymore that
you succumb and they're really straining
to think so you know this would be a
perfect way to do an experiment you
don't need very morning this California
coast essentially you have the right
marine boundary layers and all that kind
of stuff
of course protecting the Arctic region
is probably number one if you can do it
you could decrease maybe hurricane
intensity and all these things are a
little dicey to put it through but yeah
they should be tried so when you know
Erika and Katrina came in and whatever
it was ten years ago
it's sort of you know brushed on
southern Florida right and it was a
category three then I went over to go
from Mexico which was five degrees
Fahrenheit warmer than usual and that's
very picked up all this energy and so
when it long no lanes it was category
five so if you would manage in the
places where this happens to keep the
temperature of the ocean down okay that
would be great you could knock off one
or maybe one and a half essentially from
the categories so control of El Nino so
Ken called Erin students here at
Stanford have been working on this
essentially looks you look quite
interesting so you could try to protect
the coral reefs and then you know you
might look at you know global
temperature reduction at each time
there's sort of 50,000 large ships on
the ocean and if you get four or five of
them of these players which you know
it cost a couple hundred thousand
dollars that gets lost in the noise you
could actually make an impact so if if
it actually works so again I'm saying I
you know I I'm not advocating this
essentially now other adverse effects
well you know there you can stop this in
two days two days the clouds are gone
but of course if you've been doing this
for years and you stopped but you're
gonna have some consequences there's no
question about it so you might have
increased droughts etcetera and so the
only promise is so some say some yes
some say no the problem is that the
climate models the precipitation is by
and large the most thing that is dubious
the outcome that they cannot predict
with stuff so so you know this is just a
final slide or next to final slide you
know in my opinion there is no planet B
I know that Elon Musk today is in
Kalahari and telling us that it's gonna
colonized
you know in the last time this is all
fine and dandy but I think those
billions would be much better spent on
our own planet essentially I'm doing
marks that that I mean I've gained
except a good respect for him but people
can go wrong
yeah and if you look at it so this is a
picture from Voyager one I was taking
they'll call say and ask them to flip
their cameras and looking towards the
Sun again and they managed to take a
picture it's sort of all along there in
the universe no I mean that and we're
very very vulnerable you know if you
look at this for over here so this is
another one from the special you know so
this is the earth over here look sinful
in this direction and then you have the
the troposphere here and then you have
the stratosphere and then the ionosphere
this is very very thin okay so if you
take all the air that's there and you
compress it you got seven kilometers if
you make it liquid so to speak by
liquefying it okay now you have seven
meters the factor of thousand in density
okay if you take all the ice that is on
Greenland and you you melt it you would
have the same amount of liquids then you
have from all the air that's up there
you know and if you just think about it
so so the ozone hole you know big hole
why we have lots of ozone to take all
the ozone that's up there and you
compress it you have three millimeter
one eighth of an inch
that's the thickness of the ozone layer
and so many actually in president's time
discovered in 1967 that you take 20 tons
of bromine okay and let it up go put two
videos on there that's it and it goes
much faster than with chlorine and you
know we we almost brominated this the
CFCs okay instead of chlorinated but it
was a few fortunately for us a few cents
more expensive so it didn't happen but
we would have lost the ozone layer okay
before you knew what was going on so
anyway you know this this our final
thoughts you know we're now in an area
of consequences as we should I should
say you know and so it's up to us
whether we gonna keep our first you know
seat first class or the panic are we
gonna change course and so our future
isn't pretty time and I'm certainly not
without hope and geoengineering may or
may not be you know help us but we
certainly should do the research because
it's very high time to do this so anyway
and so if anyone of you is listening I'd
be delighted to talk to you over see if
you can help us one way or the other
thank you
you